Good morning, Hank, it's Sunday. It's News Day. And I'm in an airport.
Yay.
[Intro music]
So Hank, a couple days ago, I was talking to a nerdfighter named Naomi
and she said that we should bring back the Evil Baby Orphanage
and I was like, "I don't know.
Maybe the world doesn't need an Evil Baby Orphanage."
and then, North Korea launched a long-range missile into the ocean.
Hank,
it's time to bring back the Evil Baby Orphanage.
So as you know the evil baby orphanage is a fairly straightforward idea,
that was invented almost two years ago by a nerdfighter named Brooke,
as a way of resolving an argument that nerdfighters were having
over whether or not we should go back in time
and kill the evil baby Hitler.
Brooke came up with a compromise solution,
in which we would go back in time,
kidnap evil baby Hitler
and then take him to the Evil Baby Orphanage,
which would be a school designed explicitly for evil babies
in like Tibet or something.
Well, Hank, I don't need to tell YOU
how good an idea the Evil Baby Orphanage is;
the problem in the end wasn't that we found it difficult to build a time machine,
the problem was that you and I had a profound disagreement
over the nature of time travel paradoxes,
a disagreement which continues to this day, but Hank
I think it's time for us to put aside our petty squabble
because the world needs an Evil Baby Orphanage.
Now, Hank, I know that it's tempting to say that North Korea launching a rocket into the ocean
isn't particularly impressive;
I could launch a rocket into the ocean if I wanted to.
But Hank, there are a couple of important differences between North Korea and me.
First off. I'm not run by a crazy 68 year old Korean grandmother named Kim Jong-Il
What's that?
Really?
Are you sure?
Hank, I have some important breaking news:
Kim Jong-Il
is apparently a dude.
But yeah, so first,
I'm not run by a crazy dude and second,
I don't have nuclear weapons.
Even though the launch was what is technically known as
"an epic fail",
the international community is still really mad.
Even China's mad.
It's like when you go completely crazy and all your friends abandon you,
except for one friend who kind of stays with you
because she's also completely crazy,
and then finally she's like,
"Dear North Korea,
I love your totalitarianism,
and I think you've got an awesome cult of personality,
and it's great how you never let people leave your country
and you kill your political enemies.
But come on!
WTF?
Best wishes,
China."
Now Hank, I'm not going to tell you that we need to get
Kim Jong-Il into the Evil Baby Orphanage;
he's just a fat crazy dude.
We need to get his dead dad Kim Il-Sung into the Evil Baby Orphanage,
so that Kim Jong-Il never exists.
Getting Kim Il-Sung into the Evil Baby Orphanage
would save literally millions of lives
and restore Korea to a single unified country.
What? We'd have to build a time machine?
That- that shouldn't be a challenge.
I mean,
nerdfighters do everything that we ask them to do.
They ate 317 peeps for me,
you don't think they can build a time machine?
Get your head out of your ass.
Sorry Hank, I don't mean to curse,
but this guy over here, telling me what nerdfighters can't do,
is really getting on my nerves.
I mean, you call me when you built a pond sand filter in Bangladesh.
Hank, you'll see me on Tuesday.
[Singing] The people in the airport think that I'm crazy,
the people in the airport think that I'm crazy.